Once upon a time,
there lived a giant with 100 eyes.
Each of the giant's 100 women took turns sleeping,
so the giant never slept since he was born.
The
people gave the giants the
role of watching over the world,
and the giants decided to go and serve the
people.Being watched over by the giants
, peace and peace came to the people.
Ah,
one day the giant found a betrayer,
and reported it to the
people.In the end, the
giant was angered not only by the betrayer, but
by all the people, and
was killed.People sleep.  I was afraid of a giant who couldn't do anything
.
There
was no
time, no worries, and I was afraid of beings who could see and know everything anytime, anywhere
.
And the giant, who never slept like a
peacock feather,
was able to sleep peacefully.
Okay
yeah yeah yeah [music] dee nanea I'm confused yeah yeah yeah me used ni yeah yeah yeah [music] yeah yeah yeah
[music
] So for us living on Tom Sawyer Island with information,
what's important is empathy and
coexistence
And a reasonable personal space
Yes, this world is
enjoying the new business selectionism brought about by the customer center
.
Evaluated better
[Music] In the
summer, as a village nuji, public services, etc.
are indispensable for exchange What is that,
everyone?
[Music]
Come on, come on, come on 4th, you'll
know how to put out 5 shares of ice cream in the future
Hey, it's not that easy.
Go to the edge of the five shrines  I have
to find afterimage data from about 18 timelines ago, but
I'm sure I'll learn 10.
I wonder if it's still in Chaucer
Genkukan's bar carp.
Afterimage data or love value
will also disappear to
, is
n't it?
No one has ever seen it,
but if you don't become a ghost, you can't even see where you can catch
it.  I
'm sorry, I'm sorry, but even if I
agree with you,
bye-bye
to the king.
I can spend time with everyone and everyone's avatars can also
choose a character
I love A life with fans and love will raise the
tension, so the routine of checking love
is indispensable
Hey,
you logged out in the middle of school, didn't
you? Char said that even before he played from the beginning,
I heard that he was in 17 countries.
I don't know if I run out of units to skip.
You can go to school at any time.
Right eye, I'm
going to take care of my back I've made a reservation now, so it's still a good day Don't be troublesome
and go
A phantom phantom, is
n't it
Zero Car
? It
's a pastime for people living in the year Anzai died in peace.
]
no Isa
avatar is new so
r hey v hey I'm going to
upload it
key
ah piccho ah ah
jab jester
ed
me
Todo down is rare
Janpoo Hey that's a
famous car
Good luck
ah
It
's
been a long time since Machiguri, so
buy a Majideko as a pastime
[Music]
Ah,
there's
not enough love
.
If we can catch Phantom 0, we
should all be able to get a great number of people Tan
10 is stupid
Princess 0 other than Zero is the truth
Adults can always put such inclusion
Phantom tax into words That's
why 0
[music]
0 was born We are  Tokimeki love blew away together I
can't stand in front of 10 There's
no such thing as a
monster
love love love
Actually this sound is 4-0 I said it was 4-0
Cut to
rar
I also put out what I'm thinking I
definitely want
to do it
[music]
voodoo n ee 2
te na
aname
ame
Eh
[music]
Lab padded white and white
Income
already 22
Then what's going on here
[music]
That
Tocha
Why?  To my
brother,
when did
you go to a place like this?
It's my
ram It's
a chat
Hikkin [music] Hmm, let's
find it
Kaichin 0
Pin!
I can't see it, so I
can only see it in this bad condition.
I caught it just by itself
I
don't have it Ah
[music]
return Hmmm
that
[music]
Point
Eh With a
woman
Love love love
Yeah
I'm definitely
planning to get used and drunk
[music]
This guy's a woman
Any number
[music] tan th ame Charlene [music]
Yeah welcome back  It was a bar It's completely
useless No way, it's the infectious disease department that caused the top
I thought it was just a punch line
to treat,
right?  That
's why I didn't see it
that way.
Music]
Hmm 1 Huh [Music] 7 r 2 [Music] Hmm huh voodoo Suh I'm home Oh
I'm sorry Pup
I
don't know what it means, but I feel like I'm being
treated as a barker.
I wonder if you've seen the equipment in the reproduction space When
I chased after the data that this tailgate was flying I
was ashamed to find out where I was hiding underground Gegee
Wow amazing
you really
life life wi-fi system
what are you doing already  I don't know,
but if you have a taste of sentences can candy 4
hey
porore
ah ah
]
Hmm, people who can forcibly cancel the space in the region, it's compatible with poppo Ah, car, eh, why is this [music] result Patching that data with this,
but it's not Aiko I don't know what it means
, but it's a
new book  I've already passed the place I
was at the west exit, so you can't
stare at it again.
the
voodoo a Don't really do it for a little while d It
's sunny
No, but
if you tell me about zero,
right?
virtual mentioned
ana touch
Bach
g line
I don't really understand
[music]
huh
dje 4th place
sooo
then
number
ben
[music]
ah ah ah mar [music] tan Bach ah ah ah ah ah ah
this is good  Then
chargers 0
[music]
tan
night teen male
phantom 0
[music]
Before
you know it, you'll realize that I'm inside of you
Queen ann's new day
rally
[music]
booby
bl so-so day
dl
[music]  music
me
ana
ani
[music]
ana
none
[music]
ana
tan
tan tan
ana
[music]